Um, So what I'll do is um.
I'll share my screen and I'll
sort of take you through the new
platform. I believe from what
you've said, you might have
already sort of had a look at it
already.
Um, but just to set a bit of
context, this is the 4th
iteration. So we spoke on the
first one, which was, um, sort
of last year at some point. So
we've progressed a little bit
since then. Um, we have added
sort of a lot of features and
functionality. This is by no
means the end product, um. So
there is still a lot of things
that are missing such as the
ability to search. Um, we don't
have all of the data. We don't
have charts and visualizations
yet. This is also coming in the
future. So with regards to those
pink.
Blades and the colorful shades
just, um, that that's kind of
just a placeholder at the
minute. Um, so that's not what
they're actually gonna look
like. It's it's just sort of a
placeholder. So that's subject
to change. But that's good
feedback. I could pass that back
to the team.
Um, what I'll do is, uh, let me
just share my screen and then.
I'll talk through the new
platform.
Just let me know if you could
see that I'm there.
Yeah.
You see my mouse moving around?
Yep. Cool. Perfect. So
essentially, this is the new
home page. Um, this is very
similar to what you would have
seen in the first concept
release, so there's not much
change here. The only changes
that we've made is this top left
section, so you'll have a
welcome dashboard, the ability
to sort of see your saved
reports, and you could also
create a report straight from
here. Everything else has stayed
the same. One thing we have
added since the last time we
spoke is the ability to.
Save a report. So I'll go on to
that in just in just a second,
but once you have saved a
report, you'll be able to access
that directly in your home page.
Um, on that save report. Or you
could see this little icon here
which says my saved. If you
click that you could see your
saved reports there as well. Got
a first feedback already. So
actually, I mean I would
understand for sure not the only
customer you have. I would
understand if there's customers
who think that's very useful for
me, not so much because I I do
not.
Use reports on a daily basis. So
I don't mind if I have to go a
little bit more complicated way
to get there. I mean it's
complicated, it's in the header
basically, right? So actually
probably if I were free to
choose, I would prefer to have
more meaningful.
Current information on on on on
the page, then uh, the old stuff
that I saved.
That makes absolute sense,
because you don't typically use
reports that much, so you'd want
something a little bit different
than a lot of people would be.
Probably complicated, I don't
know. But as a customer I don't
have to care. I guess um would
be great.
That's.
But as many positions or or
places within the database, if
you could provide freedom to the
to the user to customize it. So
for example I wouldn't mind if
if that. If that's the way the
the platform presents itself on
1st entry, fine. But if the I
then could say hey, carve out
the left section, I'm just not
interested in that. And by
default then because it's my
personalized setting, the whole
thing would never show up again
for me and I could choose to
whatever is relevant for me to
show their.
To show up there as as a
default, that would be a great
feature.
That's another one before I
forget because I don't know if
we touch on something that would
remind me. Another really cool
thing would be bulk upload. So
for example if I have an Excel
sheet with 15 products.
And I had the possibility to to
bulk upload those 15 generic or
branded names and the database
would retrieve the whatever
relevant information for it.
Is that something you do in the
existing platform? Yes, not
many, but those who have it, I
love it. I mean, I just love it,
it feature and it's so saving me
so much time.
Fine.
Um, so that's good feedback.
Thank you for mentioning that.
And anything else on the home
page, so very good points that
you've mentioned and completely
understandable here. What I see
you mean, yeah.
Umm, OK, let let me see what,
what else advise our sales by
indication. Why, why would I
have, uh, the quick links there
that I have there is it what
once did I select it for or how
are they chosen? So yeah, that's
the idea. So if you've got a
specific data view or a
dashboard or you've searched
something specific, the ability
to save those as a QikLink and
that would be completely
customizable.
Market Explorer could also be
very cool, depending on I I
didn't like much the BI.
Um based thing that we currently
have because it offers minimum
flexibility.
Yeah. And and and and remind you
that everything that I see on
screen, I want to be able to
export in a, in a, in a in a
good way, you know, So what if
you only present like like it's
a little bit with the market
Explorer and with the other
dashboards. The problem is data
is good, sometimes even
filterability is good.
But then I don't get to the data
you know in in a way that I can
use it well.
OK, that makes sense. Um, so
yeah, you definitely be able to.
Export it and that's exactly
what you plus also affect
feature what intrinsically you
used to have in most of the
parts whenever and wherever
possible.
Uh, make it uh, possible for for
the user to edit it, to change
the time scale, to change
whatever. I mean, what makes
sense? Of course, if you change
everything, then maybe it
doesn't make sense, but but so
so that you can.
Like like in many of the of the
states where you can say you can
change the the rate of the range
of dates or the.
What was the other thing that I
had in mind?
Makes sense?
Ohh for example, if you look at
the top ten products that you
can easily say I wanna see top
15, top 20, top 50, whatever it
might be. And there's another
thing which I'm complaining
about for years now and it just
annoyed me this week and it
annoys me very much on on on a
frequent basis. OK, what was
that? And that is if so, for
example if you look into disease
like CLL kind of of leukemia.
And look at the top ten products
by sales then one of the
products is IMBRUVICA, but the
problem is to improve because
marketed by AbbVie and improving
cost marketed by Johnson and
Johnson.
The rating on the product, so
it's the same API and all that,
right? And my view is different
you know if I ask the database
what is the top ten products in
an indication then it's 10 top
the top ten products that I'm
interested in and not the top 10
marketeers of the same products.
You know if they're painful
thing there is that for one you
don't get the top ten because
sometimes I couldn't recall one
now but there are indications
where where you have.
Several products marketed by
several companies. So you don't
have a top ten, you have a top
six. Yeah, OK, you have the top
ten companies, but but top, top
six products and then I always
have to export it and manually
pull the numbers together for
the same product. The same
applies then when I go into the
sales by indication.
Then if you if if you look at
the if, I don't start out the
search with the indication, but
if I start with IMBRUVICA.
Then I get improved because
Salesforce CLL Johnson, Johnson
at the improved because sales
for uh whatever other leukemias
they have always split by by by
the companies. Very painful for
me because there's always
requires a lot of manual
reshuffling of the data until it
fits nothing.
You see I I collected quite a
some uh, no that's good. This is
this is good. When I export
forecast data the the revenues
when it when it becomes uh
figures larger than.
1 billion.
Then the semi colon or whatever
you have to to.
Umm.
Represent a number. Uh,
excellent. Many times doesn't uh
in in some exports excel doesn't
let let let me put it that way,
and some export. Excel doesn't
recognize the exported figures
as numbers.
OK, and you cannot use it really
to calculate like you do usually
in in Excel in Excel. So it
should just just make sure that
whatever I export is a number
and then I can that it adds up
all the numbers. When I with in
Excel highlight all the cells
that I'm interested in that then
I want to see the sum.
OK, cool. That's fine. Um,
something that I just wanted to
mention. Sorry because I know
we've had this call in for 45
minutes, so we've probably got
about 1516 more minutes. Are you
OK for time or are you, do you
need to stop before then? No,
no, actually I would be
flexible.
Yeah. OK. If we go a few minutes
over, would that be OK? No
problem at all? Yeah, I don't
think we will, but should be
fine. Cool, cool. That's fine.
Brilliant. So what I'll show you
then is just, I'll sort of show
you the two main sections, 1
being the ability to create a
report. I'll go through that one
a little bit quicker just
because I know that's less
relevant for you. And then we'll
look at the browse experience.
So they both contain data tables
which have the same
functionality, but the ability
to create a report you can kind
of.
Straight from the home page.
So we'll have a selection of
report templates available. And
just forgive the small font
here. Um, I'll try zoom. Can you
see that? OK do you want to
zoom? Yeah, yeah, OK cool. But
yeah, you'll be able to search
through them. Right now we only
have 3, just for an example. You
can then see in the preview and
then let's just say for example,
if you're looking at
indications.
Click generate report.
So we've moved away from the
sort of step one, Step 2, step
three, and then you have all
your data. Some of the data is
not showing because we've not
populated all of the data. And
I'll just show you the sort of
the data table functionalities.
You could then add and remove
data through here, so within the
manage columns. So this is
probably something you've seen
when you seen the first version,
but we've improved it slightly
in terms of the ability to
browse. So, um, you've got.
Yes. Yeah, I think that's
something you specifically
mentioned, which is why I wanted
to show that 200 to keywords and
you don't know exactly how you
have to define them then. OK,
very good. Yeah, cool. So you
could search within those, you
could filter on selected or
unselected.
Which would allow for a safe
that I start with the wild card
and and just take the ending of
the word and yeah, well let's
try it. A little bit logical,
let's let's try it. What do you
want me to search?
Um.
Star or what? What would a wild
card is? And then uh.
Start. So nothing's come up for
no, no, no, no not not. Store
the wild card so that it says
what's before that, before the
letters that I give you. Then it
should ignore if there's
anything before that. So what
I'm actually looking for is.
Tunip.
How do I spell that? TI. Yep
TIN.
Uh to IB exactly. I turn it. Is
that where P at the end? No B
like bravo.
Yep. OK. So that could be one of
two things. It could be that
it's not picking up the data
because the data is not there.
Is that is that a drug? No, it
actually my my idea is I would
like to have maximum freedom to
search and there's uh, imatinib,
ibrutinib or lopper rip.
Osimertinib, you know, it's
there. There's hundreds of drugs
which have this ending because
the ending actually is a ending
which is giving by The Who.
Ending in itself like like like
MAP for. Just choose map and all
all the different maps that you
have. The ending in itself
already defines a specific.
Type of of of drug.
Yeah, and that would be awesome,
of course, if I could add, if I
could, uh, search for all those
drugs of that class, because
sometimes that's the question
that occurs.
OK, that's that's good feedback.
I'll feed that back um, once you
do find something. So whether
you've searched or you've um
your browser. So let's just say
for example classifications
that's showing me that there's
31.
Um, more fields underneath that.
But let's just, I'm just going
to pick a random one. Uh, yeah.
And just as you browsed over it,
pharmacological class and.
I hope you get that cleaned up.
The pharmacological class and
mechanism of action and all
that. Ohh yeah, I always have
troubles with that. No, that's
yeah, we are in the process of
populating all the data. So
anything you add will then get
added to the bottom of this
column here active columns. You
can then move these columns
around.
So you can drag and drop, let's
say for example, if you wanted
to have therapeutic category to
be the first column on the left,
you could just put that at the
top, um, and you could sort of
add and remove as you want. So
if you wanted to remove a known
mechanism of action level 4, you
could just get that, get rid of
it.
Click apply all changes again.
I'm just sort of showing you how
the data table works. Um, so if
you scroll it, depending on how
many rows you've got.
You could. Now the top row will
always freeze, so you could
always, you could Scroll down
and you could always see that
that row stays there. And you
could also do that horizontally
is also if you wanted to, say
for example if you're scrolling
horizontally and you always
wanted to see the therapeutic
category, what you can do is.
On on each column header you
have these three dots. If you
hover over it you can see that
and then you could click pin
column to the left. So if I've
pinned to that column to the
left, so then yeah that will
always stay there. And then you
could also set it and I missed
it. And I can also reshuffle. I
can yeah exactly the mechanism
of action Level 3 before 1
exactly. So like here exactly,
exactly got it. Go back into
the.
And then, yeah, that's basically
shifted it around. I'll just
take a second to load up. But
yeah, exactly what you've just
said. And then you could also
sort by ascending, descending
and then you could also add
filters.
Um, so your filters also have a
search function, but you could
also, um, browse as well. So
that's something that we've
added this release.
And if you do have multiple
things, maybe you could even
like an Excel height empty
cells, because there might be
reason why a specific cell is
empty and maybe I don't want to
see it for that reason.
So is that something you'd like?
Yeah. But on the other hand, I I
say make it exportable and I
export it an excellent make it
there. OK, well, you can have
your own thoughts about it, but
I'm not sure. It's just an idea
that popped up, but I'm not sure
if it makes sense to make it
here.
Yeah, no worries. I'm just
sorry. I'm just going to note
that down.
This could be because some
sometimes you know, I'm I'm only
looking at data and I'm not
really exporting. Sometimes I
only want to see for because
there's something very specific
that I want to see. And then of
course if there's a long list of
products or companies or
whatever it might be and and the
the field that interests me the
most is empty then I I have to
scroll and scroll and scroll and
don't get it all on one page and
so there might be some some use
of it.
Absolutely no, that's fine. That
that makes complete sense. So
let's just have a look at the
UM, so we've seen the text
filter.
Um, let's just see if there's
any.
I'm just going to see if I
could.
Adding um some dates I could
show you the date filter.
If not, I can show you and and
the individual reports that are
set up from scratch would would
be similar. It's just that the
template gives you the chance to
start from from something
already. Exactly, yeah, OK,
exactly what you've just said.
So if I want to add a filter on
a date, then you've got a from.
So if I click into that you'll
just select when you want to
start and select a date and then
two which is.
And also got some good
solutions. Sometimes there's
still programs where where
selecting the data can be a
little bit of a pain, but that's
nice.
OK, cool. Is there any other
feedback do you have on the on
the filters that you've seen?
No, I think on a first glance in
the lot of sense and good.
Umm, is there anything, um,
sorry, I'll just show you a
couple of other functionalities
with regards to the data table
and it'd be just good to get
your overall feedback on what
you've seen on the report. So
let's say for example you've,
then you've taken out what you
need to, you've filtered if you
want to, you're happy with that
report, then you could do you
could either export it to CSV or
excel or you could save the
report. So let's just click save
report, you'll see.
Little green side, I know this
is not as relevant for you, but
it's just showing you the
ability to do that and then you
could obviously access it there,
which is and can you already in
this sandbox version exported
into Excel, can we'll export it
and yeah, of course let's have a
look.
To CSV or right or no Excel,
excel.
No problem. So I'll just take a
few seconds to actually load.
Um, just it's just running a
little bit slow, but we could
definitely show you what it
looks like once you've opened
that as well, so.
Let's go through that and then
what's you've also got here is
this reset button. So say for
example you wanna go back to how
it was, you wanna remove all
your filters, um, you want all
the columns to go back to the
original position if I click
reset table and you could do
that.
But how far does it reset it?
Does it reset until the start,
so when it was fresh as the
template was? Exactly. Yeah,
when you loaded it, yeah. OK, so
I'll just wait for this. Just an
idea. Also maybe make your own
thoughts about it would be cool
if you could freeze it
somewhere, you know, when it
kind of filled it a bit and
shuffle around with the table a
bit and you're pretty happy with
it as is for now, but you still
want to continue to to change
things that you can.
He said, and you can can restore
to an intermediate, you know,
not not back to the original
template, actually you don't
need to restore it and just
reload the template doesn't help
you much. But if I halfway
through of of editing the report
could say, OK, that's good for
now you know? And then
afterwards maybe I do something
that I don't like, but I know
that I can go back to the to the
already.
Somewhat customized version.
Yeah, absolutely, if it makes
sense. But no, does that makes
complete sense. So in in that
situation, you'd basically just
want to save that report because
once you've saved that report,
you could go back into it and it
will be the exact same,
absolutely. So that's I think
what you're referring to. Is
there anything else with regards
to, sorry, I'm just trying to
export it, having some.
Spontaneous errors at the
minute. Let's just see if I
could go back and export that
again.
And in case it won't, which
appears to be the case.
Why?
Remark would be preferably that
the table would export into
Excel in a in a smart way,
meaning that the headline.
The header is really also the
header in the Excel sheet.
So not uh, average report
extracted on that day and all
the general information on top
of the table.
Because then I have to delete it
in order to be able to filter in
Excel. I've got you. That makes
sense. So you just put that at
the bottom. If you think, well,
it makes a lot of sense to see
when you export it and what you
export and what. Maybe some of
the filter settings that you had
makes sense, but just just not
on top, not above the table.
Which is currently for example
the case in in when you export a
forecast.
The you have to. Yeah. All the
general information and that the
numbers are in dollars. It's all
on top, you know, and then I'll
just leave it on block. And so
did I get a clean Excel table?
Yeah. OK. No, I completely
understand. Can you see the
export that I've done right now
seems to be right. Yeah. Yeah.
Just sorry, I'm just trying to
expand some of these are just so
you could see. Does that seem to
be what you're after? Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah, very good. And
today?
Just remember that, you know,
this is still the 4th iteration,
so we would be sort of hearing
feedback along the way. Um, But
that's that's good to know, um.
What do I have at the bottom?
The general information.
So at the moment you won't
always useful to know when you
extract because after a while
things might have changed and if
you don't know from when it is,
then it's hard to compare. Yeah.
So at the moment we don't have
that functionality. That's
something that we're considering
on the road map. I can't give
you an exact date, but that will
come in a future release. And
some other providers actually
what they do, they would give
you the clean cut table which is
very good because typically it's
something that you want to work
with and you don't need a lot of
other stuff.
In the same page.
But would would create another
sheet with the general
information when what was it
export and what what is it.
Maybe sometimes you get the the
filter settings.
That you applied or the report
name? That the report template
name that you used from your own
reports? Because maybe after a
year you don't even remember
which of the templates was,
yeah?
No, completely. I completely
understand what you're saying.
So basically, um, yeah. So some
of the, so a lot of that
functionality we haven't built
yet. Um. But with regards to the
way the current platform works
at the point of when you're
exporting, you could alter those
variables, can't you? Um.
So yeah that the moment what we
have is the ability just to
export it as it is and without
the option to sort of include
exclude nulls, um, have for
example data definitions, cell
comments etcetera. So yeah,
those options will be coming in
future.
And so start, I mean, that's for
sure the most important part.
Yeah, absolutely. So, yeah, as
as we're building it, we're
going to sort of test along the
way, uh, conscious that we've
only actually got 3 minutes
left. Um, So what I'll do is,
um, so that's kind of the whole
create report experience and
I'll show you the browse
experience. So first things to
mention now is some of these
things are grayed out. That's
purely because they're not
active at the minute. So right
now we only have drugs and
companies.
So this is something that you've
not seen. This is something that
we've done in the last couple of
iterations. Um.
This is essentially the browse
experience, so this is the
overview page for drugs. Now the
idea for this page is that
you'll have some calculated
metrics at the top.
Um, you'll have a section for
any relevant events.
And then you've got a section
here for your top three, so
you've got your top three MOAS,
your indications at Level 3 and
your therapeutic categories.
And then you have your overview
drugs table at the bottom. So
these columns are already sort
of, um, altered for a drugs
overview sort of landscape. And
this contains the same sort of
data table functionalities. You
could manage your columns, add,
remove, export, save. And the
point is, is that when you're
filtering these calculated
metrics that the data table
below will also filter
accordingly. That's not
something that we've built at
the moment, but.
Something that's going to come
in the future. Yeah. So do you
have, um, so sorry, actually let
me just before I ask for your
feedback. And we've also
implemented a new thing called
slices. So at the moment we only
have sales and indications, but
the idea is that it's, it's a
curated view of that data. So if
you go into indications that
you'll see your columns for
indications will be slightly
different to your columns for
sales, but it's the ability for
you to sort of get a quick.
Landscape view of that data.
Yeah. So if you look into sales,
you'll see what would be
miscellaneous cancer versus
solid tumors, I mean.
You have solid and you have
hematological tumors. And what
is miscellaneous? Good question.
I would need to get back to you
on that one anyway. In general,
if possible under there might be
good good uses for the word, but
in general I hate miscellaneous
because then it means I don't
know what I'm looking at. OK.
No, that's I agree with you on
that one.
Terms in terms of this sort of
index page, this is what we're
calling an overview index page.
Do you have any feedback on any
of this so you've got your
metrics, customizability, so for
example.
What is it that I'm looking at,
13 billion in 2021? It's
worldwide sales of what?
Um, so at the moment I could be
wrong, but I think that's drugs
across.
It's all across the world, so
it's not for a specific drug. Is
that is that something that
you'd want to customize?
Yeah. So, so for example, so, so
if I understand it, whether the
current data is correct or not,
as I understand it, it's
basically a dashboard which
informs you about the current
state of global, the current
globe, some current global drug
information and it's fine.
Because sometimes it might be
exactly what I'm looking for,
but uh, would be great again if
I could then um.
The selected technology, since
I'm typically only interested in
small molecules, so maybe I
would like to see what what
we're only the small molecule
global sales. Fine. So you'd
wanna apply a filter to face
phase one, phase two, phase
three. Of course I want to see
how much of my technologies in
the pipeline and which phase and
not all the other stuff that
that that is not not my.
My business.
That makes sense. So you want to
apply filters to those metrics?
Um, in order to sort of
preferably, yeah, well, and not
only filters, but also would be
great if I could choose to make
it the default that I don't have
to do it every time.
OK. Fine to choose this, that's
a that's good feedback actually.
Yeah. And like I said before I
would like to wherever it makes
sense. I mean you're smart
people you'll find out wherever
it makes sense make it
customizable so that so so for
example in the current view when
I look look up a forecast for an
indication then I get a company
name, I get the drugs name, the
brand name, I get of course all
the forecast years but the
revenues and all that and
certain other uh data points
but.
For example, what what I do not
get from evaluate uh as a
default. It's a generic drug
name.
And I live mainly in a generic
drug name world. Uh doesn't mean
that the the brand names are not
important to me, but I also
always in addition need the
generic name. OK, so so when I
look, when I type in the name of
a drug and I get the forecast
number then then I would like to
be able to to arrange or or
define.
What are the standard, uh, data
points that this table will show
me every time when I go into it,
you know?
Fine, that makes sense. Um, I'll
take a note of that as well.
Are you OK for another couple of
minutes? Would that be OK or?
And by the way, man, I think
it's really useful.
I would have no problem with the
idea that we haven't set up
another call if it makes sense
for you. Oh, brilliant. That's
that's really good, actually. So
let me make a note of that and
happy to do a.
Yeah. So what I'll do is I'll
once we've had this call, I'll
obviously share the feedback
with the rest of the team. And
then if anyone with some more
product knowledge for example
wants to do a bit of a deeper
dive and get your thoughts on
something more specific than
yeah that would be brilliant.
Thank you for that. That's
appreciated. Um, this is the
individual so drug item page, so
we saw an overview. So what I'll
do is let me just show you how I
got here. If I then Scroll down
on here, you've got all of these
generic names if I then.
Click into each one, um again.
We've got some information about
that. So the primary branded
name, status indication, launch
indication, companies with
sales, some metrics and then a
data table is there. Do you have
any feedback on that page?
Looks good on a first glance.
Is there any um?
Any specific information that
you would want there or you
wouldn't want there?
Yeah, well I thought, well there
there's a possibility to manage
columns. To question is can I
own and manage, can I own and
manage to columns so that they
are or can I choose to see other
exactly fine. And if that then
would freeze. If I can say I'll
look into liquids. And I managed
to columns because very often
it's really the case that I'm
after the the same kind of data
for different products. If I
could manage the columns now to
my likes and then freeze that
and say in the next time I log
into another drug, that's all.
But then also how how that table
pops up then? Perfect. Ah, OK,
fine, that's really interesting.
So you actually want to save
your.
Reference columns, yeah, OK. So
that's like because you know I
guess and I would assume
probably also applies to the
former, to your former customers
typically it's it's very similar
information that you want to see
every time that you every
company has their view on the
market and competitive drugs and
and and probably you always
wanna have that view because
these are the metrics that you
think are meaningful for
whatever it is you want to
accomplish.
And of course there there might
be changes and not a problem
because, um, obviously I can can
manage the columns.
But at least if there's one view
which I need most often, then it
helps me a great deal when I can
blindly rely on I I look up a
product and wow, they're already
is my standard view with the
most often used data.
Absolutely. So at the moment you
could do that via save report.
So again, if you were to save
that report, it would save that
view exactly how it is.
Yeah, but then then how, how
when I open it up, how how would
I change the the drug name?
I'm gonna have to go into the
report and change that. Yeah.
Well then you have to edit the
report. Possible, you know, and
and typically that's maybe how I
would do it now. But of course
it's easier if you if you.
Because like I said initially,
most of the times I just had in
the the search term in the
search and just use the same and
then already the the the landing
page where it brings me to has
to write write data in in
individualized as I need it and
I'm a very happy man.
OK, that's that's a good point.
Um, fine. So I think that it's
pretty much most of the things
that I wanted to show. In fact,
all of the things that I wanted
to show you.
I did have a another question
actually with regards to some of
the data. Do you do you
typically use a um?
A mobile phone to view any data
like this? Or do you
predominantly use a lot? OK, but
maybe that's just because I'm
too old. Maybe it's time for me
to.
Be replaced? Who knows? You're
never too old. Never too old.
Um.
Uh, so do you only use a laptop?
Yes.
You can use laptop. Cool. And
the only other thing I wanted to
show you actually just before we
we part ways, is I'll just
reshare my screen.
Is some of the sales data, just
wanted to get your views on it.
So we're just going to sales.
So you see some of these. So for
example if I'm just going to
zoom in a little bit here, so
you see you've got some
information in the sales column,
you see the the the the
information is quite small, it's
to the left hand side, but you
can see the cell is quite large.
Well that would that affect you
in any way? Would you want that
cell to be smaller? Is the width
of the cell an issue?
It it is, uh, when?
It's uh.
Needless wasted space, yeah. And
I could see more years on on one
screen. Uh, without scrolling.
And of course I would.
I would pack as much as possible
into.
Into one screen.
So if there's not other data in
in in table which requires more
if there's no down downwards. If
there's not downwards any
entries which will provide more
space and that's why the cells
are have that with with that
they have then no then of course
shrink it together.
OK, cool. That way. That's
pretty much it. So first and
foremost, um.
Apologies that we've gone
slightly over. I think we
started about 7-8 minutes late
and I appreciate you mentioning
that you're happy to do a follow
up if necessary and that's been
really helpful for me. So I've,
I've taken lots of notes and
I've also recorded this session
as well, so if I want to refer
back to it, I can. The only
other couple of things I wanted
to mention just before you do go
is you've actually got access to
the platform yourself.
To to the sandbox version.
Yeah, so if you if you currently
go onto the into our website,
the current live application,
what you'll see on the right
hand side of the search bar
you'll see a blue button. Yeah
that's it. So if you follow that
you've actually got access to
the platform. So what I would
suggest you do is if you have a
few minutes then click the wrong
with it and feedback absolutely.
OK. So do you know the are you
on there at the minute?
Now you see the purple. You see
the little purple sort of paper
plane icon bottom left.
No, no, no. I'm currently
accessing the is there, yeah, in
the new platform.
Yes, I see it. Yeah. So if you
could do, you could just submit
feedback through that. OK, cool.
Is that right? One, there's
another one. There is another
one.
Now that we have that in the
better version, um other other
database providers would they
offer as asked analyst or
whatever functionality. I also
suggested that time and time
again because there's I could
have told you so many things
that don't work well within the
platform over the years. But the
problem is there's not an easy
way that I press button say
that's the problem and just.
You know, go my way and find
another solution. And if I
always have to write really an
e-mail, open up the e-mail, look
who you reach out to my, to my.
To the to the person who whoever
is taking care of our account.
Yeah many times I just don't do
that if I have a lot of work OK
especially what would be needed
is what some database providers
have and it's excellent feature
when you when you hit the ask
analyst button the database
recognizes where you are in the,
in the in the platform. So for
example we just looked at the
product pixel ban link with
yeah.
If I would press to ask analyst
button there.
The information would be
captured that I'm what I'm
currently seeing, that's that's
currently the product page that
I'm into. And then I don't have
to write a whole long story,
which costs me a lot of time.
Yeah, what I was doing and where
I'm stuck. But then I can
directly refer to the page that
I'm currently having in front of
me and that's a very useful
service and then plus.
One of the providers is also
lightning fast and and and the
people are very helpful. And I
mean I would understand if you
are a little bit concerned that
too many people use it and for
rubbish requests and and and and
you're flooded with stupid
questions that of course I
cannot take responsibility for
that. I hope that would not be
the case. Typically I don't bug
people with that. I would only
use it in a hopefully
responsible way.
No, absolutely. I completely see
what you're saying. It's very
valid. It's, it's actually a
smart, smart thing for it to
capture where you are in the
website. Um, ours is not as
smart, as, as smart as that just
yet. But on the existing
platform as well, we do have the
same feedback icon. It's at the
bottom right of the website and
so it is a bit more of a a
shorter form. So there's there's
no like big areas where you need
to give feedback, um, but yeah,
you can use that to submit
feedback to us as well and it's
the same way on the new
platform.
But yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah. But hold on. You
know there's I'm asked for the
telephone number and it's
mandatory you know and it's it's
it's not filled out so it
automatically recognizes me as a
customer. My name is filled out
and my e-mail is right. Yeah.
And I I just hate it. I don't do
it. I won't give you a single
extra term you know I'm I've
been a customer for 10 years or
so and if I ask clicked the.
The FDA analyst Pop, I want to
ask my question. I don't wanna
wanna uh do anything in addition
to identifying myself on
identified as a customer since
I'm locked into the platform.
And I'm asking to ask the
analysts button that already
should identify these. No, that
makes absolute sense. So I don't
think we're there yet. That is
something that will feedback to
the team though, because it'll
make the feedback loop a lot and
the whole feedback process a lot
more smarter.
And and better.
And honestly, you know, I mean
it's just really, it's like like
I say, I just don't use it then.
But I take my frustration with
me. It's it's not that I don't
use it and say, well, no
problem.
But no, I'm annoyed because I
said I I had a problem. I would
have liked to raised it, raised
it, but I was not willing to
spend extra time to fill out a
form and and now I have not not
not found a solution for my for
my problem. And then I go
elsewhere and that's that's my
more recent.
Experienced us start to go into
other solutions more often than
in in into yours.
OK, that's what I find. That's
yeah, that's something that I'll
definitely feedback to the team
because that's something that we
should really improve on. Um.
But I appreciate you mentioning
all of that actually, because
they it's, it's really vital for
us. I told you I'd be honest and
I guess, no, no, I feel I am. I
love it. I love it. This is the
feedback that I need. So
unfortunately, I know after
you've said all of that, when
you are playing around on the
new platform, when you do fill
out that survey and there will
be some preliminary information
that you might have to.
Yeah, we can look with that with
the better you know. Yeah, with
the. Yeah, exactly. Agree to
help you with the development of
product. That's OK no problem.
Yeah. I'm thinking more in long
term what the existing. Yeah, of
course. Yeah. No, that makes
sense. Cool. So, yeah, be a very
general feedback. So everything
that you showed me today looks
good.
Yeah, I could really imagine
that that that it's becoming a
great platform if with the
amendments that you surely will
do so and and and but I wonder
or I worry more about the.
The data segmentation, more you
know, the more the technical
part of it, not, not so much the
graphical and. Yeah, and and.
Platform part but so, so for
example with your your
multitudes of mechanism of
actions with your funny way how
to define uh indications or
diseases some way sometimes so
so um and interestingly I think
I'm I think I'm I can say that
because for example if if I look
up PARP inhibitor which is.
That's a drug that targets a
specific cancer mutation. It
works in every other database
that I use that I type in POP
inhibitor and I get all the pop
inhibitors that I would like to
see and just invalid. It's so
complicated that it's part one,
Part 2, part whatever. You know,
you slice it dice sometimes so
granular that that one gets lost
or that it's not easily possible
to find any term.
Any umbrella term that
encompasses all the drugs that
I'm actually looking for, but
nothing else which is precise
enough, and that's different in
other databases. I don't have
that problem that I'm I'm.
It can really be a problem
because if if I look for for
drugs with a specific mechanism
of action.
And I want to see how much
revenue do they generate in in
uh in aggregate, you know how,
how large is that mechanism of
action space so to speak.
And I always have a hard time,
uh in envelope to be sure that I
I really see what I want to see
because sometimes for some
reason because of the
segmentation and and and and in
the back end uh, some some drugs
are not uh, uh considered they
are.
Yeah, different bucket. Which is
why that's becoming increasingly
a problem. And I'm increasingly
insecure when I pull data or
when I look at the screen after
I did the search, to really be
confident that I know what I'm
looking at and to be confident
that it's the complete
information and the way that I
would have expected to get it.
OK. And that that that's the
problem. Because if if I lose
trust that that I that I know
what I what what I'm looking at
you know that it's complete, or
at least if it's not complete
that I know in which way is it
not completed and all. But
sometimes really it's like I
don't know exactly what I'm
looking at and that's a problem.
OK. No, that's that's a really
good um feedback. I'll, I'll
pass that over to the team as
well and thank you for raising
that.
Um, So what I would suggest is,
uh yeah, if you do have a
playground, you sorry. A lot of
things to do will raise to the
team. Poor team. They will hate
me.
No, no, no, absolutely not.
Absolutely not. This is this is
the sort of feedback that they
want. They we don't want
customers just to tell us how
brilliant it is. We want
customers to tell us how to
improve it, right. We want to
make life as easy as possible
for you guys. So, um, really
good feedback why would suggest
is from you clicking around
yourself and you know as opposed
to you seeing it on my screen,
you might find a few more
things. Yeah, sure. So play
around with it. Please do submit
feedback. I know what you've
mentioned about the ability to
write so many things.
Uh, but we would appreciate it
if you have picked up anything
else. If you use the feedback
icon um and submit anything,
then it'll it'll come directly
into our inbox.
OK, I'll, I'll try. You know I
mean she said it's not not fully
populated so I'm not sure if I
will get you the, the the amount
of data or the granularity
already. So, so that I see if
I'm missing anything or not, I
can check it out. But anyways I
think I gave you quite a bit of
feedback already. So yeah
absolutely because there will be
some people will be spending a
couple of days.
Thinking through the suggestions
and maybe incorporating them.
So, yeah, absolutely. So, yeah,
I mean, even if you don't get
time today, it could be any
other day. So you'll have access
to the platform over the next
few weeks. And what we'll do is
we're obviously doing this with
a few more customers. Once we've
then looked at all of the
feedback and we've summarized
it, what I'll do then do sort of
in a few weeks time, I'll reach
back out just to give you a
summary of all the feedback that
we've received and our response
to that feedback. Just so you
know, we could close the loop
and you're aware of sort of.
Our next steps and how we're
going to sort of start
addressing these things.
Um, but yeah, for now, I'll.
I'll follow up with an e-mail
just to um.
Just to give you a link to the
feedback survey and the platform
itself. Um, and then yeah, it's
it's completely up to yourself
if you want to do some more
testing. Um, if not, I thank you
again for your time for you to
spend an hour with me on a
Friday is uh, I'm very grateful
for. So appreciate that.
What was wrong with you
actually?
Again, well, um, yeah, we'll
we'll leave it there. I
appreciate you saying that, you
know, reach out if there is
anything else. So I'll, I'll put
that on your record as well. If
there is anything, I'll reach
out. If not, just feel free to
drop me an e-mail as well. If
you want to discuss anything in
more detail, I'm happy to pull
the right people into the
meeting as well.
Guides that sound alright?
Sounds good. Yeah, well,
brilliant. Like I said, I
haven't given up on invalid and
I hope that will establish that
I will like the platform like I
did before, you know, and that
will.
At some point be again might go
to platform where I blindly step
into and I know I can rely on
the data and be happy with it.
Please. Let's hope, let's hope
we could get you back to that
point. No. Cool. OK, great.
Alright. Thank you very much.
Tim. You enjoy the rest of your
day. Have a wonderful weekend.
Bye. Bye. Cheers. You too. Bye.